cette vidéo est très spécial pour moi
j'espère qu'elle vous plaira pour ce
huitième épisode de l'émission théorie
j'ai décidé de parler de mon jeu préféré
toutes plateformes confondues final
fantasy 8
bien évidemment c'est un rpg est un jeu
de rôle sorti sur playstation 1 en 1999
et développé par square devenu square
enix par la suite sous la direction de
yoshinori kitase et et hironobu
sakaguchi le jeu vidéo est mon préféré
j'ai beaucoup d'émotion à l'égard de son
scénario son gameplay sa bande son je
suis un réel fans
cependant même si final fantasy 8 a
connu un grand succès commercial avec
7,4 millions d'unités vendues il a subit
malheureusement de nombreuses critiques
à son égard
à cause de l'énorme succès de final
fantasy 7 premier final fantasy arrivée
en europe et qui permit de découvrir la
saga aux européens en 1997 effet fui
connaîtra alors un succès commercial par
le biais de son prédécesseur mais sera
très critiqué car tellement épais à
cause du succès de ff7 beaucoup de
joueurs seront déçus car ils ne
retrouveront pas les sensations émotions
comme quand il avait découvert final
fantasy 7 mais c'est tout à fait normal
mais on en reparlera dans une prochaine
vidéo je m'égare zaccaron squall au
début de l'histoire
un personnage un peu froid et dur et qui
parle très peu
il a pour but de devenir incident qui
est un titre militaire dans le jeu afin
de combattre le mal et défendre la
population
il passera alors de nombreux examens
plutôt difficiles comme vaincre ifrit
par exemple pour réussir son rêve
après quelques péripéties il se rendra
compte avec son petit groupe qu'une
sorcière du nom d'aidés à essert de
dominer le monde
les side entraîné pour ça squall passera
à l'action est tentera de la défaire
avec la compagnie de ses amis zèle
selphy irvine christie's et sa bien
aimée évidemment linoa qui n'est pas une
sida la base l'histoire évoluera nous
apprendrons beaucoup de choses par le
biais de vision du passé avec laguna et
ses deux compagnons quiros et ward des
soldats galba dian aider à se verra en
fait être manipulé par la sorcière du
futur nommé ultimecia et qui se servira
de l'armée de cale badia pour arriver à
ses fins c'est un jeu réellement
excellent par son gameplay sa bande son
et son scénario sur tout et je vous le
conseille grandement j'ai résumé
vraiment très vite fait pour que vous
connaissiez les grandes lignes mais le
jeu est beaucoup plus complet que ça ait
beaucoup plus passionnantes de
nombreuses théories existe sur ce jeu et
voici celle que je vous propose
ceci n'est pas réellement une théorie
car laguna est réellement le père de
school et je vais vous le prouver
tout le long du jeu ce qu elle permettra
entre présent et vision du passé
créé par sa soeur de coeur elon elle a
de très grands pouvoirs et sera
poursuivie par la sorcière adèle puis
maintenant ultime et sia carré l'one a
les capacités de faire voyager des
personnes dans le temps c'est pourquoi
l'envers à des visions as cool du passé
à propos de laguna car elle rêve de
pouvoir enfin réunir sa famille elle fut
enlevée est enfant à cause de ses
pouvoirs et laguna ira la chercher car
elle et sa fille ce col dans ses visions
du passé incarne toujours et seulement
laguna c'est déjà une référence
ensuite vers la fin du jeu avant de
mener l'ultime assaut contre ultime et
sia après avoir rencontré la bouna pour
de vrai il vous dira qu'après tout ceci
et l'aura de nombreuses choses à vous
dire mais que si on ne veut pas le
savoir il comprendrait ce que laguna
soit dira ce qu il sait qu'il est son
père qu'il a malheureusement dû laisser
en compagnie de l homme dans un
orphelinat pour finir sur cette théorie
si vous jouer à final fantasy dissidia
vous remarquerez qu en ce qu elle devra
affronter laguna que dans les dialogues
il est dit qu'il est son père
je n'aime pas cette théorie pourtant
elle existe et elle est très probable
squall serait mort à la fin du cd 1
suite au combat contre la prêtresse et
des as à la fin du premier cd ce col
avec son équipe devait faire un attentat
contre edéa dans le but de la tuer
cependant après le combat et d alan sera
un sort de glace et un pic de glace
transperce rascol en pleine poitrine
la suite du jeu ne serait donc qu'un
rêve mais pourquoi au début du cd2e on
voit ce qu elle se réveillait sur un lit
le pic de glace disparu et soigner la
théorie commence donc ici et montrera en
quoi est ce un rêve
cole avant de mourir aurait eu de
l'espoir c'est pourquoi dans la suite de
l'histoire cypher est un ennemi facile à
vaincre
alors qu'il est son plus grand rival et
que son histoire avec l'inra se
concrétise car avant le cd numéro de
l'histoire entre lino high school est
plutôt tendue ils ne font que de se
prendre la tête
ensuite toutes ces visions du passé
seraient alors des réponses sur son
passé toujours inconnue pour school
car nous avons peut-être toutes les
réponses que l'on cherche sur nous
lorsque l'on meurt puis le moment où
school va chercher linoa dans l'espace
et que le casque de celle ci se brise
school sauvera celle-ci et seront tous
deux ensemble dans l'espace
seule cette scène serait alors un simple
fantasme créé par school la fin du jeu
ou school des faits la sorcière serait
alors un salut pour ce héros mais il
reste encore d'autres détails
nous avons la présence d mumba qui sont
des sortes de lions rouges que nous
voyons seulement à partir du disque 2
après la soi disant mort de scrooge cela
ne reste qu'un détail mais cela est tout
de même très étrange trouve pourquoi par
est-il que maintenant mais dans les
visions du passé et nous pouvons
apercevoir dont un compagnie de la
guinée
donc est-ce que ce détail a pu la
théorie je pense que oui de plus ces
lions sont un symbole de school étant
donné qu'il est l'unique propriétaire du
leinster tu es oui avec sa bague et
sagan blade enfin parlons d'un dernier
argument le combat contre ultime et sia
le combat final
celle ci vers la fin du combat parle et
dit des choses très bizarres
réfléchissez à votre
en france votre sensation
vos paroles vos émotions
le temps il ne va pas attendre
peu importe combien vous tenez il vous
échappe multimédia révèlerait alors que
ce qu il est un souvenir
elle connaît son enfance elle sait ce
qu'il est à la fin du combat tout
commence à devenir floue pour school
car étant allé dans le futur il essaie
de retourner dans son époque
cependant il n'y arrivera pas et
atterrit sur une petite île rocheuse
dans la compression du temps et se
laisse tomber
il vit alors une plume blanche symbole
de lino à il l'appelle donc et elle se
retourne cependant celle-ci est
complètement buggé et floue tout ça
montrerait alors que le rêve de squall
arrive à son terme nous voyons
énormément linoa durant sa vision qui
est l'objet de son fantasme
puis nous voyons les dernières images de
lino aquila avant de se prendre le pic
de glace puisque oulmers cette théorie
est vraiment fondées et très
intéressante mais comment expliquer le
fait que lino à sauve school et le faire
revenir à la vie alors que ce n'est
qu'un rêve
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
cette théorie est l'une de mes préférées
et elle est vraiment incroyable et hyper
intéressante
commençons avec le live earth et oui le
symbole de la chaîne celui que je porte
autour du cou et chronos le liner
symbole de school scuola le porte autour
du cou sur son épée et porte même une
bague à son effigie mais on reviendra
sur ceux ci plus tard dit noah serait
donc ultime et sia il faut savoir
cultiver sia le boss de fin de final
fantasy 8 et c'est un boss mal compris
par exemple dans les autres final
fantasy on connaît toujours plutôt bien
le boss final par exemple ff7 avec ses
féroces on connaît son passé tout ça
ff10 ject est le père de titus que l'on
connaît plutôt bien mais ici l'ultime
essai est un personnage qui sort de
nulle part que l'on annonce comme boss
final le seul moment où on apprend à la
connaître et où on lui parle et lors de
l'affrontement final pourtant dieu sait
cultiver ça est importante dans
l'histoire est bien ce serait par le
fait qu'ils immédiat serait tout
simplement lino à
comment pouvons-nous leurs remarques et
déjà sur la ressemblance physique
ynwa ressemble étrangement à ultime et
sia ce sont les mêmes traits du visage
et pourtant les autres femmes du jeu
n'ont pas la même tête donc les excuses
de la vieillesse des graphismes ne
marche pas ensuite si vous parlez à
aider à la fin du disque 3 vous
comprendrez que je dis mais c'est
quelqu'un de seul délaissés et c'est ce
qui joue sur sa méchanceté et des a
quant à elle fut libérée de l'emprise
d'ultimes esiae rester dans le droit
chemin grâce à son amour pour sid qui
est son mari elle n'est pas seule elle a
évidemment school et les autres du
groupe
mais jouer au jeu pour comprendre cela
je ne veux pas vous spoiler donc ultime
et sia est quelqu'un de délaisser est
abandonné mais quel rapport avec lino à
parlons de la promesse de ce col lors de
l'introduction du jeu nous voyons linois
seule dans un champ fleuri avec écrit
comme promesse de ne jamais l'abandonner
soit si tu me cherches je te promets
d'être là cette promesse est dit parce
qu'al dans le jeu pour lino à
dans ce même champ fleuri donc on peut
supposer que linois serait revenu seul
comme on le voit dans l'impro du jeu
avec cette promesse en tête voilà ce qui
est symbolisé mais pourquoi serait-elle
seul me demanderez-vous est bien celle
là l'argument clé de cette théorie il
est dit que lorsqu une sorcière meurt
elle donne ce pouvoir à quelqu'un avant
de mourir c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
et des acquis obtenus les pouvoirs
d'ultimedia donc cela veut dire culte
immédiat et vaincu mais on parlera de ça
dans l'app théorie suivante
ensuite quand et des affûts à son tour
vaincu ultime essai a transmis ses
pouvoirs à l'inra et pris le contrôle de
celle-ci elle se servira de lino a pour
libérer la sorcière adèle emprisonné
dans l'espace à l'écart du monde pour la
sécurité d'autrui
ultime et sia délivrera alors adele qui
fusionnera avec lino à
mais vaincu parce qu'al et ses alliés
linoa regardera les pouvoirs d'ultimes
essais a vaincu par le biais du combat
contre et dix ans et deviendra donc une
sorcière à son tour l'histoire continue
puis après avoir vaincu ultimecia ce
qu'olmert dans la compression du temps
mais retrouvé par lino à celle ci le
sauvera avec ses pouvoirs de sorcières
et apparaîtront dans le champ fleuri
endroit symbole de leur amour cependant
d'après notre théorie linoa est
maintenant une sorcière et les sorcières
sont quasiment immortel dans le temps
quant à ce qu il lui reste mortelle
donc ce qui devra arriver arriva et ce
col moore aura donc de vieillesse ni
noah sera alors seul et pleurera la mort
de school et deviendra donc ultime et
sia la sorcière du futur sa méchanceté
naîtra de son chagrin de la mort 2 cuil
il reviendra alors de nombreuses fois
dans le champ fleuri comme dans l'intro
pensant la promesse de squall qui ne
sera pas respectée car ce quoi le mourra
et laissera donc linoa seul d'autres
détails font référence à cette théorie
comme le fait cultiver sia connaît très
bien les sides et les high on pourra
alors relié sahali nora qui durant son
périple avec scholes a côtoyé que décide
multimédia des voix alors une haine sans
fin en verre décide à cause de la mort
de squall et donc de sa promesse non
tenue
enfin en revenant liner soit chronos
grieves en anglais le symbole de secours
lors du combat final la seconde phase du
combat ultime et sia dit qu'elle
évoquerait la créature de vos cauchemars
elle invoque à monstres ressemblant à
lyon et du nom de grippe heures
coïncidence ce monstre symbolise school
comment pourrait-elle invoqué ce genre
de monstre sans faire référence à celui
ci ceci montre le lien qu'avait linoa
avec squall l'amour de sa vie
c'est une évidence linoa et ultime et
sia
on va faire un peu plus court pour la
dernière comme vous l'avez compris
d'histoire de ff8 tourne autour du passé
du présent et du futur
je vais seulement et non c'est la
première partie de la théorie car je la
trouve déjà très bien écrite et je n'y
avais pas pensé moi même
cette théorie s'inscrit dans le cas où
l'ultime esiae lino à
squall meurt dans le premier cd tué par
aider à le jeu se poursuit sans lui dans
les cd 2 et 3 ce qu elle ne peut donc
sauvé linoa dans l'espace dans le cd 3
puisqu'il est mort d'où la cinématique
de fin où l'on voit le casque de lino a
explosé linoa morte multimédia n'existe
pas donc elle ne pourra pas contrôler
des as qui ne tuera pas secours lors dû
céder à la boucle se refermer on reprend
l'histoire ou ce qu elle était supposée
mourir ce col et donc vivant sauve linoa
dans l'espace à leur ultime et ça existe
et l'histoire continue
cette hypothèse est intéressante mais
sachant que les événements du début du
cd de suivre directement ceux du cd1
elle tombe à l'eau
car au début du cd2 school s'étonne
lui-même d'être encore vivant donc il a
bien été touché par la magie de glace
d'edéa
mais il n'est pas mort d'ailleurs ces
vêtements ne sont même pas trouvé et il
n'a pas de blessure à la fin du jeu ce
paul meurt vraiment mellino alors et
suscite et casse la boucle temporelle
dans laquelle effet fuite était renfermé
voici une première boucle mais il ya
aussi une deuxième ultime et sia qu'elle
soit lino a ou non est vaincu à la fin
du jeu et par le biais de la compression
temporel avant de mourir donne ses
pouvoirs à edéa dans l'endroit du
pensionnat en retournant dans le passé
aidé à devient donc la sorcière
l'histoire se répètera donc ce qu elle
assiste à la donation des pouvoirs
d'ultimedia edéa constatera que cette
histoire sera sans fin car ultime et sia
renaîtra de ses pouvoirs mais pas c'est
sûr que ça car ultime esiae vaincu elle
va mourir
donc elle transmet ses pouvoirs à edéa
cependant cette fois-ci elle meurt donc
aider à eric juste de ses pouvoirs
la boucle serait alors terminée
n'hésitez pas interagir via les
commentaires c'est très important pour
moi
final fantasy et ma saga de jeux vidéo
préférés
et final fantasy 8 et mon coup de coeur
dans cette sublime série de jeux je
ressens beaucoup d'émotion quand je
rejoue à ce jeu je suis heureux d'avoir
pu vous faire une vidéo sur celui ci
car il me passionne énormément et tout
comme le symbole de ce col que le liner
soit avec vous cet argot rock est vive
final fantasy
et
à